[Music]
jordan love is he underrated
she's got something to prove today
[Music]
oh
that was good a boy there we go here we
go
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show that
prides itself on improving the video
game ratings of professional athletes
and you may notice the guy who's wearing
the exact same clothes behind me yeah
that's jordan love quarterback of the
green bay packers
why are we wearing all black because
it's a funeral for the haters why
because jordan love is wildly underrated
and we're gonna fix that today isn't
that right jordan love yes sir twin
twin
let's get more on jordan love's ability
as a player in madden let's go our pro
gamer yo boy pizza interestingly enough
we're about to do something that i don't
know probably not many people would
think about doing jordan love at punter
look this guy's an athlete he could do
it all over the field obviously he could
throw the ball he claims he could punt
though he was a punter in high school i
believe you know that should replicate a
little bit here whenever it comes to
madden right
all right looks like we got the power
and accuracy
where's the hang time on that
that went 10 yards have you ever been an
emergency bonner before i mean
high school you know did the little
quarterback punt scoot back a little bit
and yeah
kick accuracy what do you think you are
oh
42
an 18.
it's tough never like see that i have a
guy i want you to meet this guy this guy
can improve your madden ratings clint
oldenburg please come out here
clint jordan jordan clint
where does he rank as a
quarterback that punts
kick power currently 33
and kick accuracy for you 18 that his
name uh 31 among all quarterbacks he's
got something to prove today
that's all i got this is the guy that
can get it done
you heard it here first state farm
offers surprisingly great rates now
let's give jordan love a chance to show
he deserves a surprisingly great kick
accuracy rating
this is like the classic coffin corner
madden drill so that means if you get it
in the orange 10 times
your kick rating is going up to 30. i'm
aiming for that right now
clinton you ready ready jordan time is
yours okay
great lift
and it is
in the blue now that's two
that was beautiful you two
oh and that that's gonna hit a car
and it did
it hit a ford escape
i hope
was that your car no it's not my car i
don't know whose car that is and but
we'd like to formally apologize i would
definitely like to apologize
good lift bang
three
wow
[Applause]
oh and this one is straight down the
middle wind's gonna pick him up oh
so that's going to be minus one this is
the last one last one okay you're at
plus six
here we go
with the wind it is high it is deep and
it
is and it went out in the ones giving
you plus seven
now we need to talk to clint about the
hang time but i think your placement was
great yeah
man that car probably got a dent over
there for real
it's always good to see a drill straight
out of madden with the coffin corner one
of my favorites so that's fun gives us a
lot of information so average hang time
3.3 about a second lower than nfl
average okay so still pretty good still
pretty good a couple shanks in there so
while we didn't get the full increase on
these things we are gonna be able to go
up a little bit we're going plus nine in
kick power
plus nine and kick accuracy
a little bit of a jump nice nice to see
some punting hopefully if the packers
need a punter and a pinch they got a guy
i love myself a mobile quarterback and
jordan love is just that guy being able
to get out of the pocket with somebody
to evade the people on the defensive
line is always huge in madden
now one thing that i did notice was his
throw under pressure seemed a little bit
low only at an 80 overall
if his throw under pressure was just a
little bit better we might be able to
get that off a little bit more accurate
[Music]
this one is one that i think we can
improve today so i'm curious on the
rating throw under pressure that's
probably like a 72
got to be something low it's an 80
but
i think we can get that into the mid 80s
i hope so we have a drill that's going
to cool you off
uh this is your brainchild are you
excited to see him go through it i am
yeah i think that this could simulate
some things so we're going to throw some
water balloons at you in the pocket
we're going to squirt some water guns at
you and have you throw at some specific
targets and form a bottle see how you do
with that all right
let's do it let's go
he's rising
nice glasses
sweet look here
you excited for the reason you have them
on
it's okay if you say no yeah i'm not as
excited about that i appreciate you
sacrificing your body for this
hoping they're not coming for me today
we'll see they are we paid them
literally to come for you today so good
luck all right okay
i'm gonna stay dry yeah
whenever you're ready jordan all right
[Music]
[Music]
come on that's trash how do we feel how
how is this as a drill
it's tough man do i need to call it the
floor this might need to be a practice
drill okay here we go
oh
that was good
i loved that that was great
you avoided almost all the water on that
wow you know i have heard stories about
men walking on water that was as equally
as impressive as that that was
impressive all right we're going for the
second bottle now let's take a
right in the back bottle that was a
blind side sack right there bruh that
one got me that was daniel hunter around
the edge that one was tough
he drilled him right in the back okay
one more i got to hit this thing all
right jordan you got this one come on
[Music]
don't step there there's glass jordan
love is breaking things
what did you think that was a hard drill
i mean pocket presence on that his first
hit that was perfect yes but just his
ability to move around the pocket looked
really good and then we got really small
targets really hard to hit him but he
did get two yes uh so pretty impressive
based on what we saw for throw under
pressure you're gonna go up one point
from 80 to 81. nice
kick power went up nine kick accuracy
went up nine we just got throw under
pressure to go up one i have one simple
question now for you mr clint oldenburg
jordan loves is he underrated jordan
love just smidge underrated you came out
and showed us some things we wanted to
see today she went up a little bit
excited to see more nice he got soaked
wet for us clint i did we appreciate it
too welcome thank you
damn
proud of you thank you twin twin 20 20.